(Kelly screaming)
- So we always want to be
sure that you end this hour
with a little bit more
joy, you're welcome.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
Lots of people would shudder at the idea
of living in a tiny house.
Those are usually about 225
square feet and on some land,
but now a guy on TikTok is
showing off his small digs
and it's even tinier than that.
It's a 95 square foot
apartment in New York City.
Check this out.
- Wherever your expectations
are, lower them.
(door creaking)
As soon as you walk in the door,
we have the sink.
Right next to the sink, is
conveniently located the kitchen.
Pantry is absolutely stocked.
I have two beds, but only one me.
Some nights, I'm a queen guy,
other nights I chill on the twin.
Closet, that's the whole place.
- Oh my God I wish I could say
what Chris just said
on TV, that's amazing.
He is certainly making the
most of what he's got y'all,
this is amazing.
And we have him on the line right now.
What's up Axel.
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my gosh.
So how do you come to
live in that apartment?
Like, how much do you have to,
I don't know if this is a rude question,
but I feel like New
York City is so pricey.
How much are you paying
for that apartment?
- New York City is pricey
and the story of how I
got it begins like this.
I was working in Michigan
just about two months ago
and I had a job that I
wasn't super passionate about
and as I was sitting there at
my desk, I thought to myself,
I can be anywhere and
I can become anything
and I believe that's true for everyone.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- So I decided, where do I want to be?
I said, New York City.
I packed my bags in my
car and I came here.
Now this apartment
wasn't ready right away,
so I spent roughly three weeks
parked in a Walmart parking lot.
Like imagine not being able
to fully stretch out your legs
and then moving into here
on a queen size mattress
where I can fully stretch out
and enjoy the comfort of AC,
so this is a major upgrade.
The price is 1200 a month.
- What!
- But I give you
right there on the street.
Did you just scream?
- Yes.
- I'm right here in New
York, I get to walk outside,
I get to feel the buzz
of the city around me.
So it's 1200, but I get the
energy and the community.
- Okay, I love where you're
at, but when you do upgrade,
you got to come back on our show
because I wanna see what your
next apartment looks like.
- I would absolutely, I would love to,
I'd love to come on again.
And I have to say, before
we go, I'm a huge fan.
While I was driving here,
it was actually one of
the songs I listened to.
Making the way from
Michigan in New York City.
♪ Since you've been gone ♪
- I love it.
♪ I can breathe for the first time ♪
Thank you so much Axel, we love you,
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
- Thank you.
- Okay, well, that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you
who dream big.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars,
how does that sound?
- Holy (beep).
Okay.
- I love you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.